let's invert the politics because we had
another officer involved shooting a few
months ago
that uh did not result in widespread
rioting and that was ashley babbitt
so we got the story from killed ashley
babbitt we don't know
here's the story prosecutors won't
pursue charges in shooting death of
ashley babbitt during capital riot
long story short they said the officer
didn't understand what's happening she
defied
repeated commands the officer was scared
he fired he killed her
through a door through a door he
couldn't see her she wasn't holding
anything fired
blindly into a crowd
okay justified they said
these are the same people on january 5th
said we don't need any reinforcements
we don't need any extra cops we don't
need any national guard
january 6 january 5th we know all this
stuff is coming we don't need anybody
babbitt's the girl that climbed up in
the capitol building right
no she was standing behind the door the
door here she was standing
behind the door and the cop the the
capitol
uh police shot right through the door
and just killed the woman who was just
standing there okay but this is the girl
i'm thinking of the one that was the
only
person she was murdered and put her head
in the window and they saw a head pop up
and fired wait that's not a i'm sorry
seeing someone's face isn't a threat
i'm sitting here you know are arguing
that
uh in many instances there could have
been an alternative for the cop it's
it's so sad that these these young black
men have lost their lives in
circumstances
it's regrettable and then here you have
a woman who quite literally just peeks
her head
through a window and takes a bolt to the
neck there were cops behind her
what like so if you watch the video she
goes down and immediately a swat team is
right there within like 10 or 15 seconds
what if that guy fired and hit one of
those cops this to me is
they would be prosecuting him you know
he'd be investigating him you know what
it is it's very very simple
she's not human dude listen these people
mess with the seat of power
the trump supporters went to the
democrats home
business home in in these other places
it's on the streets on a highway in
portland it's outside a police
association building a federal
courthouse
yeah the democrats don't work there well
i'm still part of the seat of power for
that locality in that region
but it wasn't like they went to pelosi's
office right so all this is symbolic
which means it's
bull means it doesn't have any resonance
in fact
there's no equality under the law
anymore there's none
they're not even prosecuting or
investigating the only person who is
murdered was ashley babbitt
all those other deaths have been ruled
not homicides they're not even
prosecuting anybody
and they're not even proud they're
holding people in solitary confinement
23 hours a day people have been charged
with trespassing and some people are
being beaten by the by the guards
there's been reports like one guy was
brutally beaten and he's got like broken
eye sockets
look if you want to really get in on
details on this there's one julie kelly
check her out she has been following all
this she's been tracking all the court
cases we talked about having her come on
my podcast
check her out julie kelly she's doing
great work hi julie by the way
so what is this guy's a federal cop so
they're not he's not getting this
he's capitol hill police i mean i don't
know why they're not investing i mean
the only reason they're not investing in
because
maga patriots are not human exactly well
obviously
yeah everyone's darker yeah but it's i
mean you look at how the media
you know i'll put it this way though
super dark i i i am still kind of
optimistic for a few reasons right
i talked about the media's collapse the
rise of independent platforms like
substance
one of the projects ian spearheading now
is uh i don't we should come up with a
name for it yeah metanet i don't know
metanet
do you come up with that no we're
talking about that on a call the idea
he's gonna say it's like if you don't
have that trademark or the domain box
yeah like you don't say on air that you
wanted to do
it's an open source project free for
everyone wins
the goal is to create an open source
program that can create a subscription
platform for everybody that networks
with other platforms so
no one can be banned anymore your own
website but this is going to
decentralize the internet
and strip away a lot of the power from
the narrative machine
i take a look at cnn when we when we
google search riot and we get all this
mainstream news about the capitol but
nothing about minnesota yeah
and then we got one super chat that
figured it out for us
you needed to search for peaceful
protest oh my gosh that's
brilliant yes we did so we searched riot
and got
capital and we searched peaceful
protests and it was like minnesota
protest mutual protest mike elliott
and so i i think about this oh that's
interesting
at what point do people stop watching
cnn
because they're not getting news anymore
let me put it this way i saw a popular
youtuber i won't say their name
very progressive and they posted about
donald trump
for their like main segment and i was
like dude it's
it's april 14th yeah and there's riots
the derek chauvin trial is in full swing
and coming to an end there is so much
rich news to pump into the veins
of an unsuspecting populace instead
they're like donald trump
i'm thinking this you know a lot of
people were asking the question
what will we do after trump i remember
news
news outlets were talking about it and i
remember people asked me that they were
like
well i mean you talk politics all day
like what are you gonna do when trump's
gone i'll be like bro
or there's other things last year i was
talking about science the hedgehog yeah
i was talking about sonic hedgehogs
and and birds of prey and how the
non-woke fun kids movie was way more
entertaining
i was like i got everything to talk
about because i care about news not
politics
now that trump's out we got so much to
talk about
chauvin trial riots arrests yet how are
these these news outlets like cnn
and these progressive youtubers still
making segments about trump
at a certain point they're going to be
trapped in the past
and i imagine regular people are gonna
be watching and they're gonna be like
hey i heard about this thing that
happened in detroit and the guy's gonna
be like yeah yeah but anyway donald
trump and they're gonna be like dude
trump's not president for months
why are you still talking about this
they're going to chase trump into
irrelevancy
and i'm i'm all for it how many how many
of these progressive youtubers
actually just made their whole entire
career
out of trump right that's all they know
that's all their clicks all their views
everything comes from that
they're not well-rounded people that's
the grift baby right
so like i came up out of this little
niche in the internet called the
manosphere but i was able to break out
of that because not only was i
capable of talking about those issues
but i have like a well-rounded
background of education experience
knowledge education
i'm happy and easy to talk about all
kinds of stuff so i know
knowledge you know what i value more
than my ferrari
by the way julie kelly also from chicago
i was going to say well with a name like
julie kelly i assume her uncles are on
the police department
so no it's like they're just going to be
exposed for being one note people
one note people one no people and those
people are going to die all of you guys
out there are still making the same card
we're all gonna die that you made in
2014
you gotta evolve how boring is that life
anyway i'm i feel bad for those people
i feel bad for the people that are still
talking about trump still talking about
dating mating still talking about that
one thing that got you attention
yeah over and over i mean it's it's like
it's like being bananarama
and having to go play that one damn song
look look at look at cnn that's exactly
it
look look cnn's a great example all
right so ratings are starting to improve
for a lot of people
where we had this period after the
inauguration where ratings started to go
down because people are like okay i'm
done it's over
now interest is starting to come back in
a variety of stories and a lot of people
are reporting on like youtube and
podcasts ratings are starting to come
back it's a good day but cnn's ratings
are still going down
oh no look at
uh look at reliable sources i love that
name reliable sources okay
the best they they have this whole thing
where throughout the trump presidency
they talked about the right-wing media
ecosystem and it's
and it's fueling trump and it worked as
a media show because
it was trump's narrative networks these
these various outlets that were propping
up trump
now that trump isn't president it's just
one guy saying like i watched fox news
yesterday
and tucker pissed me off and i'm just
like i don't care
yeah i don't care what tucker said that
you don't like cause he's not the
president
he's not fueling a president joe biden
is the president but when your whole
grift is built upon ragging on
right-wing media
once they lose relevance he has nothing
to pivot to what's he going to do
the new york times announced that they
were forming the the tech division was
forming a union
oh yeah people are going to watch that
right yeah that's but that really
happened i mean who cares though
nobody cares so he's trying to milk
desperately like
tucker carlson is the new trump remember
when brian salter said that
he said tucker carlson sounds a lot like
trump doesn't he you wish
and people are just like they're begging
for a new trump we wish trump was more
like tucker
fair enough fair enough they don't have
anything to offer i i feel like
i got more enjoyment reading some news
articles and then talking to you guys
about it
than watching it on tv and being told
about it but i think a lot of people
don't have a friend
that they can talk to about politics
that's why we're here exactly thank you
for being my friend jack
i mean my pleasure sir my pleasure
the illinois boys will always be a
friend to you i lived in chicago for
three years
were you born there because you're not
hold on naperville doesn't count buddy
hey hold on i was born no i was actually
born in chicago so i have my i have my
citizenship
whenever whenever i i'm talking to
people and they're like they say
no no i'm not we're from the same
neighborhood yeah so tim and i
yeah yeah we're we're probably there
around the same time i'd imagine yeah we
left when i was pretty little but we
were right but can i say older early
docs yeah we were right by midway
yes yeah and i'm a bit older than you so
i was definitely a little kid and you
were still around god i
am grandpa over here when whenever i
talked uh and also
uh sorry i don't know if i should i
should say this was a very prominent
very very famous progressive who lived
like two blocks away from me this is
really crazy
but uh whenever i ask people like where
are you from this in chicago
i'll be like oh me too where where are
you from let's say naperville for those
that aren't familiar it's like what 40
or 50.
like i'm from iowa yeah it's like
that's hilarious dude i decided what
said someone say that to me i was like
oh what part and they're like rockford
rockford exactly so like three hours
away no
no it's like an hour to two hours but to
be fair like so i actually grew up in
the suburbs we left the city when i was
pretty little but not naperville not
that far away i mean
i will never have to stand from
naperville it's a big place there's no
question about it yeah yeah and like
to be fair what are you supposed to say
i'm from naperville where's no one knows
where that is chicago no it's also true
yeah so i just tell people the philly
area because we were in the jersey side
so it's not literally i know like
chicago
the first time i went to do your show in
philly right i'm driving up to philly i
get a hotel in philly and i like put in
the address to go to your house
places new jersey it's 10 minutes from
downtown
it was 10 minutes from downtown that's
the thing it's literally you're downtown
you cross the bridge you're there
i know i know still what am i supposed
to say to people
so i i'm from southern new jersey dude
i'm not from
there no one's gonna make it our show is
there sorry sorry thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time